okay everyone we are doing a live stream
about uh functionality for version 13.3
of awesome language we're specifically
talking about the service deploy
functionality second of a series
uh
the basic idea is that service deploy is
lodging
what is essentially a callback an API
function to be called back
from from an external service is that
correct
not necessarily because the two services
that do implement the service deploy
interface right now don't Implement a
callback they're basically like kind of
some kind of mini clouds you run on your
own hardware and so there's no callback
there it's just an API okay so is it
right to have a single function that
does this I mean one thing to do is
you're service deploying an API function
is that but in all cases your service
deploying an API function true or not
true
or scheduled task or something is that
correct or is that not correct it's not
necessarily an API function but yes well
what is it what else is it I mean it
could be a URL dispatcher a form
function or whatever all right but it's
one of our static page it could be a
static file
right maybe any expression right yeah
yeah pretty much
any expression that is lodged with an
external service
yeah for some definition of external
depends on the service right like I mean
there's some Services where you know you
can host basically arbitrary you know
yeah I'm sorry we had corrected this
wording why is that not showing up here
we made a change to that why is that not
showing up here
right remember that
I don't I I I I remember that we didn't
like the anonymous go back and watch the
freaking video and make it the change
please
yeah this isn't right fix it
I'm gonna I'm gonna overwrite this file
then
in fact unfortunately because I didn't
update documentation I might overwrite
other files so I probably shouldn't do
that
okay but please please make sure that
these things are actually executed
yes will do
okay
all right so let's go over this again
this is
I'm going to start making my own notes
Here
first version of this notes is from 2019
so this is the second part version
okay so let's take it from the top
service deploy
it's not a okay to a service right
that's the destination service
and
okay now you have this thing what we
talked about last time and fixed yet
right
that doesn't make any sense what you're
saying here
right we talked about that last time
didn't we
guys yeah yeah okay so why is it still
there you didn't change it I just went
through the video I don't see the edit
yeah talk about what it should be we
talked about what it should be
yeah but Stephen at the end of last
meeting we weren't sure that we're gonna
change the argument structure to this at
all
right well we were certainly changing
the wording because the wording doesn't
make any sense but these uh but there is
there is an older but it doesn't make
any sense it needs to be changed that
the dogs are out of date even by last
say it again
okay well so once I update the
documentation I'll see it again and then
I will push back changes okay wait wait
Stephen the point is this is a proposed
change from the service deploy notebook
that is in the was packlet
we so since I'm working on Wolfram web
engine I want to make that less just was
and make it work for other things
including or from web engine right now
and maybe something else in the future
okay right so that was my proposed
change what was your proposed change I
don't understand what the documents you
just closed was my documents are just
closed are not acceptable documents
okay
and we went through that last time
yes but if if if the the zero hypothesis
here is the null hypothesis it's not to
change anything from what it is right
now for both that's not going to be
acceptable to
but that's what we were floating at the
end of the meeting that the argument
structure didn't need a third argument
we're not talking about the argument
structure we agreed that the
documentation was not right
documentation isn't right because
there's no design
if we don't know how many arguments this
function have how can I write the right
documentation for it
all right
well if you'd given me some notes from
last time it might have helped
right now this just seems like a Time
waster
I did shoot off in an email uh the The
Notebook that should work now that's
opening on my machine yeah I see it I
think there's a chicken in an egg you
know either the docs have to come first
in order to look at the design or the
designers should come first in order no
no I know I know that's fine so but
let's let's go through what it is we're
trying to do here and let's not get
confused and let's not talk about
really kind of annoyed that we don't
have the stuff from last time here
that's really not okay
I'll make sure that doesn't happen again
okay let's let's go through here
all right
is this still what it was last time yeah
everything still what it was last time
okay so we have to start from scratch
basically
okay what are the services that we are
currently planning to support
for 13.3 was and Will from webng
no that's not right we've also got other
things we know okay we've got those
we've got the the
um open AI AP opener AI stuff right
which am I wrong I mean which doesn't
support service deploy so far we can
make it yeah that's what I'm saying so I
mean let's discuss what it is
you know targets
okay
we've got
open application server
and that's deploying apis right API
function Etc is that correct with
anything
so it includes a file
yeah
okay next
what's the next web engine
okay and it's the same thing right a bit
more than was because specifically what
for example was done in support URL
dispatcher
why not
ask Andrew
I was never cleared so so Aubry please
find out
I I strongly suspect it's just a bug
okay so
find out
I don't want to hear it's just a bug you
can get it then get it fixed
but then there's a there's there's a
number of things like some interpreter
types don't work on walls it's it's
weird
okay so let's find out why
okay
another is another thing that we had
right that we talked about before now
what are the other ones we've got Bots
like the telegram bot
is that correct
not in 13.3 I understand that I'm saying
targets that's what I said here
right let's go through what we what we
are planning to do
or what we are thinking of doing okay
Alexa skill I don't know if Alexa is
still alive but we'll find that out
okay
we've got
um
open AI plugin
should actually be T plugin
we've got what else do we have
we have telegram bot potentially
we've got I don't know
Discord and slack Bots okay all right
Discord bot slack bot
whatever other things like that okay
anything else
that we know of
so let's look at what the typical thing
we need for these uh oh
so a male receiver function
that's actually its own thing so this
really should say mail server because
that's what it is and what it what it is
trying to go to as a mail receiver
function am I right
do you see what I'm saying a mail
receiver function could be
that's the thing that is called with
certain arguments by the mail server
is that right
yeah I'm just confused about just
calling it a mail server because I don't
think you can like we went through this
the other time you it has to beat the
cloud mail server not just Daniel mail
server
no that's not correct we went through
that last time it's not correct
what it has to be able to do is to Lodge
an email and it has to be able to
install something or whatever it is the
proc mail file or whatever it is that
says run this code which is an API in
the cloud
on this piece of mail on each piece of
mail that comes into this address
did you understand what I'm saying
yeah you're saying that a general
feature of mail servers is that they
allow you to assign some code to be
executed or something exactly when and
what has to come back
okay is
right and so this is we went through
this last time it's a disappointing
we're having to go through it again
you know right now we have implemented
this for the cloud for the mail server
in our cloud
could be implemented in the PC it could
be implemented in another kind of mail
server am I making sense
does that make sense do I need to repeat
no no it doesn't make sense thank you I
don't know the technical details of okay
that's fine I'm trying to get a design
that where we actually make forward
progress here
okay so now for for example the track
GPT plugin the interfaces API functions
that true or not true or it's a rather a
URL dispatcher
I don't know what you mean by that I
mean like there there's
I don't think like okay right now it's
its own thing it's a chat GPT endpoint
or sorry plug-in object
in the future it might be possible to
stuff it into a API function or
something maybe this is a good idea just
like mail receiver function isn't an API
function yeah I think it's more like
that
yeah I think that in general what you do
is like just just like Todd did for
Alexa skills you take a specification
which might have its own head or might
not and then turn it into one or more
API functions that's why you need to
deploy function and not just anything
but this is saying we've got two
different things going on here so if
every one of these has its own custom
you know
well I think it's just just when you
call service execute different Services
expect different kinds of arguments I
think this is similar okay but so let's
discuss what kinds of things go in here
because these ones have communal Garden
symbolic objects am I making sense
yeah whereas this one has its own custom
exotic plant well I think it's basically
the first two are services that happen
to be able to display basically any HTML
and so that's why you can you know why
you can do these fancy things
there are other ones that that you know
like a mail server doesn't you know it's
not it's not displaying HTML among other
things and so you know there are other
things you can deploy to it
right honestly the first two seem like
they're probably the outliers and that
they're so flexible in their inputs
yeah well the question is
I mean I expect all the other ones you
know there's going to be a Discord bot
object or ideally not exactly but you
know what I mean
right but if that's a symbolic rapper
that's its own name
that's something we have not done not
for uh you know service execute not for
import and so on what about can I say
something
I I think that for well I mean one thing
that was clear to me while I was trying
to code up the uh the telegram bot is
that uh there is a situation where you
want to deploy an API function which is
an API function and and it doesn't get
messaged into anything
so I think that some of these would
support API function especially like the
telegram API changes very often and so
there might as well be things that you
can only do if you could the API
function that's the web hook entirely
from scratch
and you know things like what the Alexa
skill does which messages the arguments
into an API function is a convenience
that sometimes you get but not
necessarily you want to get I'm sorry
I'm totally confused look what we're
doing is we went through this before I
I'm disappointed that we're going
backwards here right remember these
hierarchy okay we have a service type
okay so each service type
presumably associated with the service
type is a you know has things you can
deploy to this service
absolutely yes okay so each one of these
Services has a certain set of symbolic
objects that can be deployed to that
service
true
so let's decide for example for an Alexa
skill
what do we want to do here do we want to
have an association which allows you to
specify all kinds of key value things
that might change as the Alexa skills
interface changes or do we want to do
something different where we package it
up like a mail receiver function
I'm not sure about the mail receiver
function analogy but in the case of an
Alexa skill there's a bunch of
information that you have to that that
belongs to the Alexa world that you have
to specify to create a skill sometimes
normally you do that on their website
but there is a way to do it
programmatically nowadays and you could
imagine that that service deploy to
Alexa could package up all the
information you need to register with
Alexa for your skill in some huge
Association right that's that's it's
imaginable thing right
so the question is do we want to have
custom names like this
right
or do we want to have an association
there
so Christopher can I look at what you
have for the um is this is this um
where's the thing that is the chat GPT
scroll down on the on the notebook on
the right and there's a there's links to
the documentation
well on the bottom yeah okay
the first one the second one the API
functions I think isn't quite as
flexible as it needs to be
ignore the packlet symbols
well wait a second but
what would you do if you were doing this
with associations
could you would it be reasonable to just
say service deploy try TPT
Plug-In or something and then here yeah
you probably could cons I'm thinking how
you would do that yeah you probably
could construct it with just
associations
[Music]
um
yeah well some of the value of having it
not just be associations is the fact
that
um that these things support
like sub values so like if you have the
endpoint object you can get stuff like
oh give me the API function that this
endpoint will be turned into but that's
that's only useful for kind of niche
cases well okay but but maybe it's
better to I mean one possibility is
every one of these is a packlet
every one of these the thing it deploys
the packlet and you really expect to
have these external symbols in there
because we definitely don't want to put
in the system you know right this week's
you know uh yo well it could be some
kind of service I mean I think service
object is taken for something else but
it could be some kind of service
object-esque thing
um
but yeah I mean I think right like in
this case yeah I think it probably could
be just an association yeah
okay but is that the general thing I
mean in in
my I mean okay I mean General anything
can mean associations
that might be an ugly thing yeah
I mean like I can try and let me see
I'll try and convert this one to an
association see what it looks like okay
okay
uh I mean it'll probably nested
associations right I mean this would say
yeah
I'm just gonna see if I can format it in
a way where it's not like totally
incomprehensible what's going on
okay all right
so
all right first level is a service type
second level is the server
the specific server
now what's deployment instance
remind me what what's an example of that
instance is like it's like what the
cloud object is for the first two
like where you put this thing and how do
I reach it as a URL
for Bots it might be which specific part
like either the name of the bot or the
token of the bot
um
Alexa skills as well like you can deploy
multiple Alexa skills
um to the same API
okay so the sub part of the deployment
is really something
this is inside the expert
yeah all of them will have it yeah I
understand that but I mean that's the
URL dispatcher or the multiple endpoints
or whatever else
so that does not have to be represented
in the first or third argument
s right
okay so service type
okay the specific server
so is it obvious that we can't package
together
yeah we were planning to package those
together is that a correct statement
uh service type and the server yes it's
ready I mean service connect is already
in system and documented and well used
so and how does it but how does it
package those together well service
connect when you connect to a service
then you you get back service object
that represents all right okay so so
this is packaged with service type
as a matter of fact you might even have
two different connections to the same
server with different permissions going
on at the same time yeah okay so that's
a service object so now why is the
deployment instance not in the service
object
well because you don't want to create a
different service object when you have
to deploy 15 API functions to the same
instance of was you don't want to you
know sometimes you have to rewrite one
so I think at least for the first two to
me it's kind of obvious that it's useful
to have something that you can reuse to
rewrite on top of something
okay
okay so deployment instance
your arguing should be the third
argument of service deploy for given the
experience with Cloud deploy for the
first two I have no doubt about that or
the others maybe there's some discussion
to be had but what do other people think
about that
what is the location but for each of
these other things
okay so for these the location is
the cloud object for a mail server the
location what might be the mail mail
uh the email address
am I making sense
I think yes yes
okay
for an Alexa skill what is the
deployment instance it's a URL or it
could be a cloud object it's essentially
a cloud object
and what is it used for it's used
because okay so so for the Alexa skill
there's only one server right
right the actual server is is sort of
not part of what you care about it's
just electric right
okay but Todd I I'm thinking like for
the Alexa skill like for the telling bot
you have at the same time like a pointer
to the specific skill and the pointer to
the cloud object right well at the
moment you don't have a pointer to the
specific scale because there's no way to
you don't programmatic do that from the
local language if we had a way to do
that
I'm not saying you do it from the
Wolfram language but once you created
the whole skill Etc
doesn't the Amazon API give you like a
token
no you you give your url to them to the
Amazon API you say this is the address
that you call when this guy but in
theory just like for the Telecom bot
there could be like maybe they have an
API endpoint that says set web hook to
this URL so that you don't have to copy
paste that URL and go put it on on the
website
right they have a full programmatic API
for setting up all aspects of your skill
so yeah you could Supply the URL
programmatically
so but yeah we got 10 more minutes for
this meeting so let's figure out what
we're trying to achieve here
okay okay next up chat GPT doesn't
really have a third argument
as as it is done right now with the
limitation of the API
okay like it's one per server so
one per port
right
that's a very specific issue for right
now
yeah
um and you could imagine that you know
in a world where
I don't even know how this would work I
mean right there might be some World in
which you have something like wolf and
web engines that can that can deploy to
different sub domains and things
um
this isn't that horrifying
yeah there are two versions there
actually one of them which is if you I'm
not sure if you can do that but if you
can squish everything to API function as
well and it's actually kind of nice
so yeah
all right fine
okay
so what do we have to what else do we
have to figure out here so service
deploy
we think we understand how that works a
service deployment
is the return value of service deploy
correct
but it could also be a third argument
like for example was I understand that
is an override that overwrites and
existence is that correct just I just
want to be clear about that yes yes
that's that's what it does it overwrites
an existing deployment
correct yeah synthesize a service
deployment to specify where you want to
put things you would only get it back
oh no I I if you look at the second last
example of service deploy that I added
this is in this file here yes yes like
watch for example the last example
include definitions of the last in the
in the main section okay that one so
like was likes to have extra information
other than it doesn't just have one
location it has resource and endpoint
and resource dive and stuff like that so
sometimes you want to specify more
things then you get an another service
deployment out which contains that
information plus more once it's created
it okay I'm totally confused I'm totally
confused and you're saying
that
this is metadata that you want to be
able to just give this is wrong
you want to be able to give a naked
expression here unlike in this case
where the expressions are deeply
decorated you see what I'm saying you
want an El Cheapo I want to give a raw
expression here I'm going to put all the
details that here are in that payload
expression you want to put them in the
services yeah because those things are
not the same
but those those things are like very
specific things to how was was designed
and they just tell you where to launch
that expression doesn't they don't they
don't change the expression in any way
see if you like
that's the same thing here
View and organize files on a computer
has nothing to do with changing the
functionality does it well it kind of
does because it tells the the it tells
the the the chat what do these do what
do these things mean what do these mean
so okay so the resource I I don't know
why they split this and it's not a
single thing but the end point why did
we do this meeting without Andrew if
we're talking about how he was invited
well where is he
why did this meeting get started when we
didn't have one of the people who was
supposed to be here his list is optional
on the invite
and I mean look I don't think Andrew has
weighed in that he is fine with Carlos
suggested changes and any other changes
to service deploy he's basically okay so
I don't understand would somebody
explain to me why are these things being
put in this you know we got to have a
consistent way to do this why are these
being put here as opposed to being put
in some kind of decorated Association
here
because I think that you're sending that
expression to a location
that is like it's like why is the
permissions uh something that comes out
of the cloud object not of the payload
you you come of of this first started
it's the same thing there like they they
want to be able to specify separately
where they put resources and what the
URL to reach them is that then you have
to specify what the URL to reach them is
I thought that's exactly what this is
here
endpoints are or whatever yeah but I I
don't know what why specifically they
did the different thing because we don't
have the people in this meeting we need
the people in this meeting if we're
gonna We're not gonna have a mystery
meeting
but we're wondering why they did that
maybe they thought it was more flexible
but in general you you might have like
for example for telegram
it's the same thing you have the the API
the you have the telegram API token and
you have the wall from cloud location
those are two places you need to Lodge
this thing in
and if we did the Alexa part
programmatically you would also have two
places
I understand it's calling a specific API
in the cloud
right yeah that's what you mean by it's
a particular place in but that's exactly
what's happening in the chat
specifying an API function yes even when
it says when it says uh this sets the
web hook that URL read of URL build Etc
contains a token in there that thing is
where you log it on telegram
apis yeah so you have two URLs that you
have to wait wait a second
there's a big mess here which we already
have with mail receiver function as we
went through last time but you seem to
have forgotten
okay the problem is that if you you know
for example in one of these things it's
going to deploy a cloud
it's going to deploy this API function
in the cloud which means there's a cloud
object associated with that
right
yeah right
so there is an implicit there are
multiple things being deployed in the
case of mail receive a function there's
a an API function being deployed in the
cloud and there's also something being
lodged on the mail server that
represents the that is the equivalent of
web hook for the mail server correct yes
do you agree that those two things are
substantially different which two things
the the the cloud object and the email
address are not the same thing as an API
function or a mail receiver function
they're not Warframe language code
they're metadata
no I don't agree no I don't agree the
way that this is set up here this will
implicitly deploy a cloud function a
cloud
you know a cloud object with an API
function and then set up the appropriate
web hook or whatever it is calling
stuff to get to that API function
same thing in these other cases exact
same behavior
right it's the exact same thing I don't
think there's any difference at all
am I missing something
yeah I think that you know the this this
uh chat Deputy Thing Once you point it
to a server it's deployed to that server
and it is at the root of that server
with all the stuff that you put in that
Association that's just the detail of
how things are set up
but on the other hand there you can say
wait a second I don't want like when I'm
doing a service deployment was I want to
take maybe like this file put it in this
resource which is different from the
resource I had before but pointed to the
same end point and so those are all
locations
they're not payloads
it's just that it's a two-pronged
location just like for mail receiver
function whereas the chat GPD thing
doesn't really have locations
why
it has locations it's deploying Cloud
objects that's a location uh well no
well okay hold on right now it's not
because the main version right now is
deploying quote-unquote to localhost
yeah right right if we have a version
that deploys to the cloud then well it
depends on how we address the sort of
whole sub-domain system in the cloud
maybe those are just secretly Cloud
objects
right right well yes
but but even then it's a little
complicated because well let me see I I
guess actually it is just one Cloud
object with a URL dispatcher in it
probably
okay
yeah but but still you would put in the
third argument you would have a sub
domain you would not have the prompt
sure
okay normally in a location here you
would have the name of a cloud object or
something like it or a URL is that
correct
but here you're saying there are
multiple things you want to get you
there might be you know the the way I
did is like you can put a string there
it's gonna synthesize the the resource
and just put it in an and you just
specify the end point I think it's a
mistake to have that be I think if you
want to overwrite a service deployment
you put a service deployment there if
you want to create some kind of thing I
would just put an association there
so I'm saying because it's not going to
filled in a bunch of the elements
to be a standalone service deployment it
better be the case that you can just you
know given that service deployment there
should just be a way to call it
there's no guarantee that the service
deployment you put there is a callable
service deployment
I am fine by me I can put an association
client I I don't I'm not married to the
to having service deployment that's the
third argument okay fine but notice
there will be a service deployment as a
third argument if you are overwriting an
existing service deployment
correct
okay
but in the generic case you might not
specify everything needed to have a
service deployment
yeah sure
so you shouldn't call us a service
deployment if it is an incomplete one it
should just be an association
okay
then the output should surely be a
summary blob because it's often going to
have multiple URLs and God knows what
else
am I making sense
in this case it should say service
deployment well from application server
you know it should be a multi-deca
summary blob which says the hierarchy of
things the server type the server
you know Etc right
okay I think we have some kind of plan
here
everybody feel okay about this plan
anybody object here
okay Todd if there are further things
that come up you need to kind of Crispen
them up and we're probably not going to
have a chance to have another meeting
about this
so please get the documentation sensible
go listen to the what we did last term
you came up with a reasonable sentence I
forget what it was
makes sense
yep yep
okay okay anything else anybody wants to
raise in this meeting
we recovered it we're not even over time
disappointing that we even had to do a
second meeting but it is what it is
um
all right let's not lose the place where
these things are now already have you
got what place these things are yep yep
I do
okay
thanks guys and uh
um
actually Nick has commenting on the live
stream here deploy a local directory a
list of files to make a simple FTP or
HTTP service on a file server
yeah well that's what
that will be another example of a Target
wouldn't it be
I mean it is supported by both walls and
WWE we don't have a simpler one okay but
uh yeah I mean sure could be done
okay existing FTP yeah
okay good stuff all right thanks guys
see you later